israel's longest-serving prime minister
could be thrown out of office on sunday
benjamin netanyahu is trying to upset an
alliance of
right-wing left-wing centrist and arab
lawmakers
that claim to have just enough votes to
take away his power
charlie dagger is in tel aviv with the
effort to break israel's long-standing
political deadlock
well the stage is set for the most
volatile political period this country
has seen
in more than a decade israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu has accused
the new coalition aiming to unseat him
of the greatest election fraud in the
history of democracy
a coalition co-led by former ally
naphtali bennett
who heads an uneasy alliance across the
political spectrum
that includes an arab islamist party for
the first time
the crisis comes just weeks after
fighting against hamas militants
and in the middle of a corruption case
against
netanyahu charges he denies netanyahu
has already been accused
of stoking unrest and the israeli
security chief here has warned of
violence in the days ahead
the man now poised to be the next
israeli prime minister naftali bennett
has told netanyahu to let it go and not
leave a scorched earth behind him
for cbs this morning charlie dagetta tel
aviv